How to dress for the Female Gaze.
The female gaze is all about comfort and creativity over flattery.
So let's start with a maxi skirt.
It can be any color, fabric or print that you like.
Time to add a layer on top.
Choose your comfiest, chunkiest,
oversized knit. For shoes,
let's make a statement with either a bold color or a chunky silhouette.
Let's accessorize. The more bling the better.
Then we'll add some interest
with a hat that doesn't match the vibe of the skirt
and some sort of Bandana or scarf.
Finally, let's add a bag that matches the vibe or color of our shoes.
And now that your outfit is focused on interest rather than flattery,
you're dressed for the female gaze.